my name is ben brode i'm the game
director on hearthstone and welcome to
Archstone support Diedrich
there's nobody a blizzard have a better
idea than the coin to balance going
second in hearthstone the answer is no
nobody does we did have a lot of ideas
about how to balance going second the
first idea was just the player who goes
second gets an extra card right that's
it and we noticed that with just that
one change the first turn advantage was
60% was 40%
I took a 20% difference it's significant
right and we wanted to get it to about
55 percent 45 percent that's about the
first turn advantage of chess and we
tried a couple things the first was what
if the player who goes second starts
with more life right because what often
happens is first player has an advantage
that they put the second player on the
back foot and they struggle back but
over time that extra card makes a bigger
difference especially what you get 10
mana and it starts to even out and they
can come back so let's give this HIPPA
player a little bit more of time but it
didn't make the gameplay feel good
enough because they were always on the
back foot so we tried things like what a
player 2 starts with a 1-1 minion in the
battlefield
what if player 2 is first minion gets
plus 1 plus 1 it's just got a free buff
for their first minion and these types
of changes really started to make player
to feel like they could overcome that
advantage and get back into the game and
start fighting it out but the thing that
made us feel the best was the coin it is
a couple things one it's a very active
thing you get to choose how you use the
coins pretty skill testing figure guys
want to use it earlier in the game or
for a big swing turn later on it creates
a moment right when you play the coin
you're a poor goes oh oh it's the coin
turn what are they gonna do and that's
cool too and it does significantly
affect the first turn advantage we got
it I think the last time I looked at it
was like 51 to 49 percent it was very
close it's closer than a lot of other
strategy games and we think that's great
the coins doing a great job for us from
spivey of the ebon blade what are the
chances we see cards added to the
classic set actually this is very high
the classic set is meant to set the
baseline fantasy of warcraft in the
hearthstone universe it's meant to
provide players with a baseline of power
so that they can build some satisfying
decks
the classics it's one of the most
powerful sets in the game right now
that's the kind of kind of a problem for
us because it doesn't rotate like either
sets do so if there's a really strong
deck these are almost entirely classic
and basic cards the standard of iron it
just won't change it'll be the same
every year I think that's we needed a
format that does change every year
that's why we have the standard format
so we've been rotating some cards out of
classic and that's been causing some
disparities in the number of cards per
class mage has less cards than any other
class in standard right now because of
the Hall of Fame so I think we have some
opportunity to give made you a couple
more cards we'd have to do it carefully
because we had two powerful cards two
maids and we have the same problem we
had before the Hall of Fame rotations
where the the the decks are the same
every year and maybe displaying the same
cards every year so it's okay that
they're playing some cards every year I
think there's a base line of cards it's
good to have it's very powerful in those
sets we did rotate some into the Hall of
Fame I think we'll bring some back maybe
less powerful ones maybe the ones that
set the class fantasy really strongly
and also give you an idea what that
class identity is but I'm not sure what
those would be just yet from Sebastian
career oh god what led to the decision
to add hero characters like lord
jaraxxus it was a really creative
mechanic at the time actually this is a
great story because we were doing a play
test with one of the engineers from the
World of Warcraft team Pat Dawson and
this is way back in the early days of
hearthstone and we were still
experimenting with ways to represent the
Alliance and the Horde as different
factions which we eventually scrapped
but every class had an alliance hero and
a horde hero and for us that the first
warlock horde hero was Cho gall in the
Alliance we had trouble coming up with a
satisfying Alliance warlock hero so we
went with the one that I could remember
most which was Wilford fizzle Bane from
the Grand Tournament and Pat Dawson sits
down for the plate test and chooses
Wolford fizzle bang and then we're the
Warcraft Wolford fizzle bang tries to
summon a fearsome doom guard for the
players to battle but he accidentally
summons her exes eredar lord of the
Burning Legion who destroys Wilford
fizzle bang and takes the place of the
doom guard is the new boss that the
players have to battle so Pat Dawson
sits down and he selects will for
physical bang and he says Wilford fizzle
bang is there a jaraxxus card in this
deck and there
wasn't and I was like ah well that's
that's a huge mistake and so I
immediately went back to my desk and I
designed lord jaraxxus who would you
summon him he destroys you and takes
your place as the new boss and that's
how we came up with that whole mechanic
all right from magician mu if we have
nerfs in the game how about buffs I
believe they're cards that would benefit
from it I agree with that there's a lot
of cards that would benefit from a buff
but generally nerfs happen when
something is way out of proportion with
the rest of the cards and we have to
bring it in line but buffs imply that
like maybe we want to get everything
into this thin narrow band of power
level that's actually just not the goal
right we have cards that are
intentionally bad maybe because the play
experience they create isn't as fun or
we want to create a challenge for
players who really like to win with bad
cards or the segment of our audience
that prefers beating you with cards you
think are bad it makes their wins feel
better so we don't necessarily want
every card to be in that thin range and
also we'd like printing cards that in
the future we'll make other cards better
right a lot of the pound and Secrets
we're pretty weak but that meant that we
could create cards like mysterious
Challenger that made paladin secrets
much better and all of a sudden well
there's a few cards we could really
change the meta and you know maybe maybe
we did a too good of a job but the story
is challenged here but it lets us use
those cards in the future than a big
impact when new cards are released from
green the assassin with three more sets
becoming wild and possibly more wild
players due to the current events and
the rotation are there plans to make
wild sets purchasable with the in-game
gold and actually a lot of people don't
know that you can actually buy wild sets
and adventurers on our websites through
the battlenet shop you can also if you
ever bought like a piece of an old
adventure while it's still in rotation
you can actually completely finish out
the rotate the the wings you haven't
bought yet with gold but we are trying
to keep the in-game shop very clean and
very simple we don't sell a lot of
different products there just the recent
expansions and so we've tried to keep
that on the websites and out of the game
client where possible that said there's
a lot of people asking for this and it's
something that we would consider going
forward this is from Joshua the
paid in turn you should fight for a
higher wage sir will dungeon run be
updated to go with a new expansion well
we just announced the newest expansion
of the hearthstone recently and we have
some exciting a single-player content
there it does follow along with the
theme of dungeon runs the way that plays
but it's got a different take Trevor
we're exploring kind of a more monstrous
side and doing some monster hunting so
it'll play a lot like dungeon runs but
it's got some fun twists I think players
will enjoy here's a question from Andrew
is taking candle which is shame on you
Andrew which college degree do you think
would help most with becoming a
hearthstone world champion and I this is
controversial I don't know I would just
say forget college just play hearthstone
there's no class on how to become a
great hearthstone player find other
hearthstone players that are quite good
and ask them to for advice put together
a play group and play a bunch of
hearthstone but don't though your
parents see that that answer Kristin I
haven't playing hearthstone in over a
year
what oh but I want to get back into it
are there any resources that could help
me yes certainly I mean there are lots
of people online talking about
hearthstone on the hearthstone subreddit
or our forums or a lot of people
streaming horse them all the time that's
a great way to get back into hearthstone
you'll see a lot of the popular decks or
some of the new cards that have been
released without having to go in and
playing on your own but also you just
come and play hearthstone
we won't bite from negative rainbow it's
tournament mode going to have sideboard
support side boards in hearthstone would
be so nice it's not but I will say that
tournament mode is kind of a misnomer
with our Indian tournaments that we're
working on right now it's a specific
implementation of competitive support
for hearthstone specifically meant for
you and your friends or for small
communities or fire said gatherings to
get together and have a competitive
experience together and we're gonna
start out pretty simple we're gonna have
things like conquest and last arrow
standing you'll be able to choose a
number of decks built into the
tournament but we want to really listen
to players figure out how we can make
that better over time and continue to
add features and support it going
forward
often our tournaments only play with a
single deck one time right if you win
with this deck you've won or if you lose
with the
that gets its out of the tournament in
case of last year of standing and so you
actually don't have a lot of
opportunities to go in and out of the
sideboard which is essentially a
separate group of cards that you could
sub in and out of your deck so the
current formats we're using wouldn't
make great use out of it but we'll talk
about those kinds of things going
forward can't wait to get feedback from
players and how they can make
tournaments better from FC Chan why
aren't their female kobolds there are
hard to tell maybe for Mike where did
the inspire mechanic go our IP well you
know we could bring it back someday
we don't have any plans that we've
announced but I really like when we come
up with new mechanics that really
explore new space right inspire was a
lot of fun for us to design around we
created a lot of cards in the Grand
Tournament that really cared about
interacting with your hero power in new
ways we explored a lot of the space that
we were interested to explore obviously
there's more space there to explore I
think we might go back there someday but
we have a lot of really fun ideas and we
do want new sets to be exciting and
groundbreaking and inspiring so we'll
explore some new spaces for now but who
knows we might go back and check out
inspire in the future
astral Ben when are we gonna see Pei Pei
in hearthstone at least a card back
we love that little bird less than three
you know we haven't we haven't talked
about it we had a pip a meeting that we
were gonna try to figure out where to
get him in and it got canceled somebody
had a conflict so I'll get that back on
the books and we'll chat about it from
cinder side will there be ways to get
old card backs yes there will be ways to
get old car backs we've had actually a
lot of conversations about what the best
way to do this is I think there's an
interesting thing here right because if
you give them if you just give let's say
hey everyone here's off hook our backs I
think a lot of people would be pretty
upset right we worked pretty hard to get
those card backs it makes us feel
special that we have card backs other
people don't have so I think we have to
make the friction to achieve an old car
back pretty high but that said if we
make the friction too high and make it
feel kind of too expensive I think that
also could make people feel upset so we
have to figure out the right balance
there and the right way to deliver those
old card backs that feels like it has
enough free
but we're still working on that from Sam
spires it's Q block a concern slash on
your radar yes it is on our radar and I
think it could be a concern it's kind of
interesting it's a very skill testing
deck which is generally very good for
hearthstone right to have these decks
that are in the hands of a player hasn't
played a hundred games of its pretty low
win rate in the hands of a player's
played over 100 games a very high
winrate that's good that means there's a
lot of interesting decisions to make and
you play it differently against
different decks so I like that and
overall I like to figure out is the
power level too good there are there are
decks that are more powerful than it so
that's not the only metric but it's
something to think about is the next set
gonna have an impact on its performance
that's not another thing that we have to
figure out as well it's also there's
another component which is just harder
to use data to get at which is how does
this deck feel how's it feel to play
which I think actually pretty good and
how does it feel to lose to which I
think we're still getting data on some
people really don't like losing to it if
some people have found ways to interact
with in emerging way but we are looking
at it I don't think that we're totally
unconcerned with Q block or warlock but
I don't think we also want to be tuned
major key about how we respond to
potential imbalances especially with a
new set on the right from J through hey
BD brood what's your favorite golden
card I want to craft it in your honor
please don't say a Milhouse I actually
saw this tweet and already tweeted at
him actually went through every card in
the collection and looked for my
favorite goal of guard and I saw
crushing walls and I was like wow that's
an incredible golden animation the walls
are literally crushing the people in the
picture and so I mentioned that any
crafted is good on you from darling in
the Franks with so many expansions out
now and more to come soon have you ever
given any more thought to increasing
deck sizes or perhaps making 60 card
deck variant which uses its own separate
game mode actually we literally have
tried this exact idea every game should
feel different it's fun when you're
having a different experience each time
it could be because players are coming
at you with different decks or because
the way that your deck plays out is
slightly differently each time and the
more cards you have in your deck and the
smaller the limit on the number of
duplicates you can have in your deck the
more different each game will play out
so we actually tried
mode where you had to have 60 cards and
they literally all had to be different
and that created this really interesting
experience where the games were very
different over time it also has an
effect it's harder to build a cohesive
deck so I think it's the kind of thing
that might be fun for a tavern brawl or
something to play with for a while
let me in on a core mode for the game at
least right now from mark Fanta when are
you going to add a spectator random
match button to the menu I love watching
people play but don't have many friends
oh I'm sorry mark I think it's because
I'm a Slytherin has to expect a hashtag
hearthstone well we don't have a plan
for that right now but you can go on
Twitch
and just select a random stream I just
started watching somebody it's a great
way to both see the game that's playing
and hear your thoughts but I think it's
a really fun part of the spectating
experience that's a lot harder to do
through the in-game spectating from nick
period question mark exclamation point
will you ever add an award for fully
leveling up your hero well right now we
have golden cards that as you level up
your hero you get more and more golden
cards you're in your class cards first
and then the elusive basic neutral
pinions and so you do get rewards all
with a level 16 I think it's one of our
more satisfying progression systems
because you get experience points
whether you win or lose and it makes you
feel better about losing if you get
something like some XP so I'd like to
extend that system in the future we
don't have any specific plans about how
to do that
but I think it'd be nice if that system
lasted a little bit longer than it
currently does Thomas Z dance wicks with
the reverse nerf I'm multi giant does
that mean the team 5 is looking at
Reverse other nerf cards in the future
when they rotate the wild like spirit
clause or the caverns below while I
reverse the Giants nerf and not other
cards molten giant has a following I
would say really when we nerfed a bunch
of cards going into the standard
rotation one of the biggest reasons
behind some of those nerfs was to make
sure that the standard environment had
the ability to change over time molten
Giants was specifically nerfed for that
reason because there was a bunch of
archetypes of decks that were
specifically enabled by molten giant so
once we came up with the idea of the
Hall of Fame that we really came up with
that idea because of the community
response to the mountain giant nerf then
we could move car
it's out of the standard environment and
into the wild format which is great for
playing the cards that you love in that
format we felt like Molin giant was the
perfect car to move into that format
it's not too powerful there hopefully
and you get to play those love decks in
that format but there are other cards
that maybe are just too powerful I'm not
enabling certain deck archetypes that I
don't think are as good of a candidate
to move to wild but we're gonna analyze
those on a case-by-case basis going
forward thanks for watching I hope I
answered your questions this has been
harshtone support with wired